when I track is the natural experiments
that that is that they absolutely
explode the feminist explanation because
there's a there are a few institutions
out there without any gatekeepers and so
it allows you to test you know the the
explanation for lack of fifty-fifty
male-female is inevitably sexist
discrimination so let's look at the
places with no gatekeepers a that's
Wikipedia mmm-hmm
the editors of Wikipedia there's no
barriers there's no historical
preference so I don't know where you're
going this place but it ends up being
it's overwhelmingly male why because
males on average and I'm not talking
about your daughter
Ben Rubin the Dave Rubin listener you
know she's gonna be a no belet's but on
average yes males are more interested in
facts in things in ideas in accuracy in
sports trivia and they're the ones that
want to get involved in that discussion
are you concerned that all of our
institutions are going to succumb to
this stuff like it seems like every 30
have no it's not I mean I know you think
that 2020 is going to be the the year it
all crashes apart well I think I think
politics is is self-defeating it can't
go any further I wish I shared that so
what I yes so I'm basically that why
what I think is gonna really happen not
that it will ever burn out completely
because I think it is so psychotic in
nature and unhinged from reality but I
think this election will cause it to
have a necessary split something like
that so the split that we talked about
earlier about the AOC and Biden should
not be in the same party I think enough
people are gonna fully realize that that
the social justice worries will carve
out whatever their thing is and then the
other sane people will have to decide
are we still Democrats or are we gonna
become Republicans but yes I don't know
will it crash to the point of that
they're gonna give up well these people
show no signs of ever giving up well
again I hate to sound apocalyptic but
again message that I know that I'm
inclined towards that yeah
by definition but it is impossible to
overstate the the power of the assault
on meritocratic standards in our culture
today colorblind gender blind
meritocratic standards there's not a
single institution that is not on the
defensive if it has any kind of
achievement standard that has any kind
of disparate impact that does not result
in exact proportional representation
whether it's 5050 males or females or
you know minority based representation
any any standard whether it's in the
STEM fields in science that does not
result in in that Halcyon proportional
representation is now under assault some
Christian private school right that is
listed some of this something like that
that's very conservative yes yeah maybe
I'm always cheered on whenever I see a
panel that's coming out of some
think-tank and it's all males I think
you know and frankly let's be honest I
mean what I track is the natural
experiments that that is that they
absolutely explode the feminist
explanation because there's a there are
a few institutions out there without any
gatekeepers and so it allows you to test
you know the the explanation for lack of
fifty-fifty male/female is inevitably
sexist discrimination so let's look at
the places with no gatekeepers a that's
Wikipedia mmm-hmm the editors of
Wikipedia there's no barriers there's no
historical preference oh I don't know
where you're going this place but it
ends up being for women it's
overwhelmingly male why because males on
average and I'm not talking about your
daughter Ben Rubin they're Dave Rubin
listener you know she's gonna be a no
belet's but on average yes males are
more interested in facts in things in
ideas in accuracy in sports trivia and
they're the ones that want to get
involved in that discourse recently we
saw there was the history
matchup of three greatest jeopardy
winners they were on male if you look at
I wrote about Scrabble championship
there's no barriers to entry for
Scrabble like all of the winners
throughout history of a very short
history have all been male so if we were
to take this back to what we discussed
earlier where then the lefties would
maybe look at a separate SEC set of
facts to explain that they would say
something like well it's because we
teach boys to care more about math yeah
or something like that and we just say
know that there's biology before that
absolutely absolutely the turns out the
most gender equal countries are the ones
that have the biggest disparities in
preference for professions right so this
is the Sweden experiment exactly exactly
and and again this has not been the case
for so long we've had again strong
females together that has been the ethos
of American education now for decades it
is just not possible to say that females
are being discouraged from math it
they're being encouraged at every single
moment that there's any male
mathematicians is a miracle it just
shows how strong that imperative is at
the extreme versions again we all know
the distribution curves males are the
worst math dummies but they also at the
highest end the the the most math gifted
do you think that there's just a certain
amount of cognitive dissonance that
comes with us a lot of this like did you
happen to see a couple weeks ago Stephen
King sent out a tweet that he's against
diversity in arts because of course you
wouldn't want painters and authors and
creative people to have to have some
sort of diversity quota but this guy's a
lefty progressive you know the whole
thing and he's definitely for diversity
quotas and all the other things but not
in arts huh and I think it's partly
because he's an artist yeah so it's like
not in my field because we're creative
and creativity should always rise to the
top but for you people but in essence
what he's saying is well doctors and
pilot the rest of you you should it
should be based on skin color and
sexuality and below but not artists cuz
word hilarious well I'll take it I mean
if he's nor easily it's actually willing
to defend their it's because that is I
mean anybody who subjects himself to the
New York Times arts pages that it's all
it is it's all it is is diversity female
and people of color diversity so his
position it may be a narrow one but I'll
take it because right because they're
the kernels they're at least right so
that it's like maybe something can grow
out of yes but it's also on the other
hand I really relish the fact that
Hollywood is being pressed to sacrifice
its best box office judgment yeah for
the gods of diversity you know and are
they where you know they're absolutely
torn which do they do do they choose to
have female remakes you know that may
not be the box of cells or may not be as
good in order to placate the you know
the Oscar bean-counting and the Golden
Globe bean-counting or do they just say
to hell with it we're just gonna tough
it out I don't know I don't know but
it's really great yeah
what are the interesting times limits I
sense you're pretty enthused about sort
of the way the world is it like
everybody sort of seems everyone feels
like it's crazy it's never been worse we
hate each other more than ever poor I
mean I think all of that is nonsense
anyway and social media makes us all
feel a little crazy yeah but you seem to
even though this is serious stuff I mean
you're talking about institutions all
being infected as you're talking yeah
but it's a pleasure to be have an event
of a fellow skeptic here and and I would
say to get back to an earlier question
of yours you know are we heading towards
a point of no return and how do we get
back from this this is the most
difficult thing the way we actually
demolish identity politics and again the
the founding engine of this is disparate
impact we have to counteract the myth of
bias that as long as the only allowable
explanation for socio-economic
disparities is the tana he see Coates
view of the world the Michelle Alexander
of the world that everything is driven
by bias the aoc world they win but if
we've lost the schools already which I
suspect do you think we have certainly
certainly at the college level but even
if we've lost each other and he's lost
all of that then suddenly this rosy
picture gets a lot more murky right
yes I am NOT I'm not a rosy person all I
know is the way we get it back is to
start giving alternative explanations
and then if people are terrified to talk
about no excuse me there are behaviors
the education gap I mean what we see now
it's tragic
your average black 12th grader reads the
level of your average white 8th grader
that is HUGE forty percent of black
eighth graders on the National
Assessment of Educational Progress this
is one of these national standardized
tests
forty percent of black 8th graders do
not even have basic math skills basic is
the most it's you know simple arithmetic
those types of statistics make this
expectation of proportional
representation ludicrous yet the
cowardice on the part of our mainstream
institutions cannot be overstated if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell